c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être rick stéphane plaza on va faire
un match en trois points trois points
qu'est ce qui va se passer si vous
perdez six mois je gagne donc tu vas
chez tf1 nu c'est dur oui bon en culotte
en culotte et oui il est justement grâce
à jean michel maire de mon passé une
vraie balade en a beaucoup c'est
exactement et ainsi si je perds vous
allez chez tf1 et vous nous faites une
petite visite de tf1 comme si vous
vouliez vendre tf1 d'accord c'est pas
maison à vendre c'est tf1 à vendre
d'accord d'accord ça pourra se ranger en
trois points
vous voulez faire une ont fait pas de
balle d'essai ont fait pas de baldé
alors sachez le il joue bien il joue
bien c'est vrai mais qui commence qui
tire si je peux me permettre excellent
généralement chez vous quittez vous donc
allez-y commence à l'étoile hummer ont
trop peur tu vas dire non non non mais
où l'on vide on démarre pas là à l'usap
est content dit alors posé trois
questions
il devrait très longtemps ça il ya de
pression sur la vie des gosses
[Applaudissements]
aulas à la taxe à 0 aie aie aie j'adore
2 0
[Applaudissements]
c'est moche c'est foch
oh non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]